the prime minister is due to lay out his
road map
out of lockdown in about 10 days time
the government says the number of
coveted patients in hospitals will be a
key factor
in deciding when restrictions should be
lifted the significant pressure on the
prime minister from mps
on his own back benches who want the
lockdown lifted and fear
that the goal posts may be moving one of
them is the conservative mp
jeffrey clifton brown thank you very
much indeed
uh so jeffrey for joining us so when
boris johnson
sets out his roadmap in the week after
next
sometime what are you hoping he says
well i think what he's got to really
consider is the balance between
keeping us locked up and the damage
that that could do to the rest of the
nation in terms of
people's individual health their mental
health possible suicides
the immense damage to business as
opposed to
um keeping the
coveted situation under control and i
not sure that he's got the balance right
he's talking about
letting schools go back on a phase basis
at the beginning of march which is
causing
teachers anxiety because they've got to
keep a hybrid system of virtual and
actual learning he's talking about shops
being open in april
and pubs and clubs my hospitality
industry is in the cotswolds
in may now that is far too long
they're absolutely pulling their hair
out and i think he's got to get this
balance between
keeping us safe from kovid but allowing
the economy to open up
and start to function our lives function
as normally as possible
but lifting lockdowns too soon didn't go
so well last year we had a second
lockdown
by what was it early november where then
after christmas we had another lockdown
early january and also we've had sixty
thousand covert deaths since november
yes but that was before we had a
vaccination program
now we know mercifully that the first
four cohorts are likely to be
met by the 15th of february that
accounts for about 80 percent of all the
uh death cases that are likely to people
are likely to die
so there is no reason why april the vast
bulk of the economy shops clubs pubs
restaurants shouldn't be allowed to
begin to open
it really is essential so you would
start opening up
before elderly vulnerable people had had
their second
jabs would you well they're they're well
protected after the first jab
the second jab will be beginning in
march for a large number of people
so by april not only should the most
vulnerable those one to four groups
have been vaccinated but i would guess
most of the one to nine groups will have
been vaccinated so we will have
vaccinated
a very significant proportion of the
vulnerable people in this country
so there is no reason why we shouldn't
begin to open up the economy
and and we've got to in parliament
vote on the extension of this regime or
something to replace it
on the 29th of march and i think the
prime minister will need to think
very carefully the program he puts in
place of it
because otherwise he's likely to get a
difficult time in parliament but he's
being told by people like susan hopkins
who was speaking on sky news
on the the learn the lessons program the
other night
that there should be restrictions uh
they should last until at least
all adults have been vaccinated and i
guess by vaccinated
she means two doses that could be much
later
in the year couldn't it and i guess the
whole point is while we've got the
vaccine
program let's protect it and just you
know be very cautious about this
over the next few months as i say
if you're too cautious you do equally as
much damage
as if you lock down unlock at a sensible
time
we've got to start to get this nation
back to normality
in a relatively soon timetable we've got
the vaccination program
it will have vaccinated a significant
proportion of the vulnerable
adults in this country by april and we
really
need to considering opening up the
economy then so
so um when would you be thinking of
opening bars and restaurants and gyms
and so forth
well if the if the pattern of hospital
cases is the same throughout the country
as it is in gloucestershire which seen
it has seen a significant fall
in the last week or so i can see no
reason
why those sorts of hospitality
industries shouldn't be able to open in
in uh really by easter at the beginning
of april but
certainly uh during the month of april
and they are
really being hammered at the moment
because uh
they are industries that have very
little
financial backup behind them if they
miss both easter
and the may bank holiday they will be in
serious trouble
so opening bars and restaurants
um here what about people heading off on
holidays
even in this country um or um
certainly abroad what is your view of
that this this summer because that
raises a different issue of people
coming back with
from countries that where vaccination is
not as
progressed as ours exactly i think
people traveling abroad is much more
tricky because they will be going to
countries
that haven't had the compromi
comprehensive or early vaccine program
that we have
so i take a a much more realistic view
of that
people going for staycations in this
country for goodness sake our
hospitality industries
in places like the cotswolds desperately
need these people to come here
and people are getting pretty fed up if
not
more than fed up by being locked in
their own homes
and it really is about time we get back
to normality
and allow people to go on a staycation
there's no reason at all
why that shouldn't be able to happen uh
late late april or early may
i mean i've talked to a lot of business
people and they say the one thing
we don't want definitely don't want is a
fourth
lockdown so would it be better to take
it cautiously take
it slowly and you know make sure that
the
as many people as possible can be um
vaccinated
well of course this is a matter of
difficult judgment but i would say that
if you've as i've already pointed out
i'm sorry to repeat it vaccinated a
significant proportion of the vulnerable
uh people adults in this nation that is
a very different situation to what we
had at christmas where nobody or
virtually nobody had been vaccinated
so i think what they should do is go
back to the tears situation
allow areas like mine in the cotswolds
which currently has a
pretty low level of inflection infection
below
80 cases per hundred thousand allow them
to gradually
open and just see how it goes i
accept we don't want things opening and
having to be immediately closed again
but my guess is with this vaccine it
could be done perfectly safely
so you're talking really about opening
up before
scientists are sure about this issue of
transmission
after having a vaccine so there is a
risk here so you say
you know we'll see how it goes once you
open up you you open up don't you well
what we do know what
that what we what we do have fairly hard
evidence is that there's pretty good
protection to the individuals
that have been vaccinated that is as i
say
in groups one to four at least accounts
for at least 80 percent
of all those that have um uh had sadly
passed away so far so you are taking out
or protecting
quite a big section of the population
that is the most vulnerable
and i think we're beginning to see
evidence now that actually not only does
it protect the individual but it does
provide some protection of actually
a transmissibility of the disease okay
uh sir jeffrey clifton brown thank you
very much for being with us thank you
thank you mark thank you